behind the tranquil appearance something
important is happening in these homes
and across german society
a nation worrying about energy shortages
now beginning to take action
here's an example in these blocks of
flats the boilers will now be turned
down overnight when the lights go out so
does the heating
it is a sign of things to come more
changes are inevitable and uncertainty
creates nervousness
nazmir is 83 she's got alzheimer's and
her daughters worry about how she'll now
cope
with
told us he'll rely on a heavy blanket to
keep himself warm he says germany only
has itself to blame for relying on
russian gas imports
the flow of russian gas into germany has
slowed once more the nord stream
pipeline is operating at just 20
capacity
that'll mean that the money-saving
measures won't stop when you leave home
for weeks now europe has been basking in
a heat wave but make no mistake winter
is slowly approaching when a lot more
energy is used that's why germany and
the rest of europe is nervous about gas
supplies and that is why the swimming
pool isn't quite as warm as it used to
be
the heaters are off the water's now
chilly maybe that's why nicole had the
place to herself
i like it cold
i'm happy with it but i know a lot of
people who won't be happy with this
germany's a nation formed on industrial
might for its businesses it is an
unsettling time the current um problem
is the big
uncertainty what will be next we are
highly dependent on energy supply and
political decisions made in moscow and
that's a
situation we've never seen before
this is europe's richest country long a
bastion of calm leadership now germany
is facing a horizon that seems suddenly
unsure
and nervous
adam parsons sky news cologne